lashes like these in the Himalayas and
the Hindu Kush mountains which store the
most ice in the world outside the Arctic
and the Antarctic scientists say they
are melting and here's what might happen
they could threaten your home and
livelihood depending on where you live
if you live in any of these areas on
this map these are the bluish green
which show the Hindukush Himalaya region
and additionally in this area that's the
shading in yellow which shows the areas
covered by ten major river basins you
could be at risk of flooding electricity
shortages and food insecurity in some of
these areas these events could peak in
the next 30 years this dire warning is
part of a new study released by the
International Center for integrated
mountain development it claims that one
third of these glaciers will melt by the
end of the century even if current
efforts to reduce climate change succeed
and if they fail they will melt by
two-thirds at risk is the livelihood and
security of nearly 2 billion people for
more we are joined by dr. David Moulton
director general of the International
Center for integrated mountain
development in Kathmandu in Nepal and
this is the organization that released
this report dr. Mullen good to see you
and good to have you with us for our
viewers in India Myanmar Bangladesh and
other countries in the region what does
this report mean you know this report is
the first time that we've really painted
a complete picture of what's happening
in our Great Himalaya mountain and the
picture is quite concerning yes we have
glaciers but in addition to that we have
more impacts of climate change for
example monsoon patterns changing higher
temperatures and this will impact
agricultural systems river systems we're
about two billion people live downstream
and and all the businesses in them the
drinking water system so it is it is it
is of great concern and what it means is
that we
to act fast to deal with this but then
your report also says that even if the
world met its target said in the Paris
Climate Action report even if those
targets were met the glaciers would
still melt by 1/3 therefore is a game
over already that's correct so it's rare
it's a rather scary scenario we'll lose
one third of our glaciers basically
that's what it's telling us but if we
can hold the line to one-third of the
glaciers I believe we'll figure out how
to adapt and deal with it the
frightening part is if we don't do
anything with climate change and the
emission trends continue really - we'll
lose two thirds of the glaciers and
think about all the impacts on people on
the environment and agricultural systems
as well that will be the hit that will
be extremely difficult to handle
also think about disasters in the region
floods and droughts but then wouldn't
those disasters happen in any case even
if the glaciers melted by one-third as
well yes so we definitely even with a
melt of one-third what we have to do is
act quickly right we have to figure out
how to adapt how to get for example
flood early warning systems in place how
to change agricultural systems I believe
that we can do that in that one with it
with that one point five degree world
scenario with the one point five - or
the one-third glacier melt
it's just when we go on that where we're
really stretching the limits of how far
people can adapt so it is important that
we hold the line on climate change for
the mountain people are you really
optimistic that that line will be held
that the world will get together and
keep temperature increase below 1.5
degrees okay I I think that 1.5 degrees
is going to be really really tough but
we cannot go the business-as-usual
scenario emitting at the same rate we're
going it's just going to be a disaster
for people in this region so the mess
combined with everything else we have to
act quickly on climate change for the
mountains and hopefully that message is
received in time dr. David Moulton
director general of the International
Center for integrated mountain
development in Kathmandu thank you very
much for speaking to us
you